rerevenez. On va parler de touta
avavec quelqu'un qui connaît sa
susur le bout de ses doigts.
E Enrico Ciccone, député libérl
dede Marquette et ancien joueur
dede la Ligue nationale de hock.
DeDepuis quelques temps, vous
mimilitez pour qu'on mette les
frfreins sur cette violence
grgratuite. D'abord, votre
didiagnostic hier soir? On va
rerevoir les images. Est-ce que
popour vous c'est intentionnel,l
vovoulait faire mal?
- - Premièrement bonsoir. C'état
d'd'une violence vraiment inouï.
OnOn voit le joueur qui est
prpratiquement la longueur de la
papatinoire pour venir donner ue
mimise en échec. Je connais bien
l'l'entraîneur headset Jets de
WiWinnipeg, il valorisait le jeu
phphysique, finir ses mise en
écéchec, passer des messages por
lele prochain match. Quand on et
enen série éliminatoire, il faut
jojouer à répétition contre la
mmême équipe, on veut passer des
memessages de la sorte. Cependa,
j'j'avais aucune référence avec
cecette mise en échec. 18 ans
d'd'analyse au OK, j'ai une
cacarrière de 10 ans dans la lie
nanationale, j'ai été ce pendu
auaussi et vraiment, c'était un
cocoup qui était sans précédent,
paparce que ce genre d'assaut,
dadans la glace libre où la joie
nene se retrouve pas dans la
babande, on va devoir prendre ue
dédécision et créer vraiment un
prprécédent, une jurisprudence
popour  être capable de se fierr
ce genre de coûts pour le futur.
- - Vous dire que c'est sans
prprécédent pour vous, que ce
cocoût, parce qu'il ne l'était s
prprêt de la bande à cause de la
vivitesse et qu'il est visé, ily
a a quelque chose que vous avez
jajamais vu.
- - Effectivement. Quand on voit
çaça char d'assaut... des pénals
d'd'assaut, il y en a durant la
sasaison et pendant les matches.
OnOn le voit pas de façon
rérégulière, mais o on les voit.
MaMais souvent, le choix va se
reretrouver dans la bande et va
êêtre frappé directement à la
ttête où le joueur va être frapé
dadans l'angle mort. Mais de cee
fafaçon-là, face-à-face avec une
foforce gigantesque, c'est très
rarare et j'ai hâte de voir la
dédécision qu'on va prendre du
ccôté du préfet de discipline de
lala ligue nationale comment ila
prprendre sa décision, parce
ququ'habituellement, on retourne
enen arrière et on va voir le
jajardin pénalités de suspension
ququ'on a donnée. Mais cette fo-
cici, j'aimerais pas ça être das
l'l'souliers du préfet, parce qe
j'j'ai communiqué avec des gens
trtrès près de la ligue nationae
etet on lui met beaucoup de
prpression pour qu'il donne le
mamaximum des cinq partis de
sususpension.
- - Pour vous, est-ce que c'est
susuffisant ou vous auriez voulu
ququ'il soit suspendu pour toute
lala série.
- - Mon avis sur la glace que ls
gegens des premières lignes, les
ararbitres qui ont été là pendat
lele match et on l'a vu pendante
mamatch, je l'ai regardé, on vot
quque ce choix, qui est une jour
ététoile, un très bon joueur de
hohockey qui n'est pas habitué à
cece genre de geste, on voyait
hihier qu'il menait du tapage. l
auaurait pu avoir quelques
avavertissements de l'arbitre,
mamais on ne l'a pas fait. On na
papas protégé. Les arbitres sont
llà pour protéger les joueurs sr
lala glace et c'est les résultas
ququ'on a vus hier pour passer n
memessage qui est déplorable.
- - C'est intéressant ce que vos
ddîtes. Vous dîtes que
l'l'entraîneur... c'est comme sl
avavait demandé à ses joueurs :
momontrer aux Canadiens qu'on pt
êêtre durs et passer des
memessages. Cette culture, quand
elelle va disparaître pour baisr
jujustement, je ne dis pas que
l'l'entraîneur a dit à ses joues
: : il faut passer un message.
C'C'est cette culture. On est
prprogrammé de cette façon. On t
élélevé des très jeunes âges de
cecette façon également. Quand n
jojoue un match, on dit : parfa,
ilil faut laisser notre marque t
dodonner le rythme pour le
prprochain match. Aujourd'hui, e
m'm'élève contre ce geste de
viviolence inouïe notamment chez
leles batailleurs... des rappors
onont été écrits par des médeci,
dedes spécialistes comment
l'l'commencions cérébral peuvent
vevenir affecter une personne à
lolong terme. Monsieur Roy, je
m'm'élève à chaque matin et je e
dedemande avec mes cinq, 6,7
cocommotions cérébrales, est-ce
quque je vais commencer à fairee
lala démence? Est-ce que je vais
fafaire de l'Alzheimer précoce?
J'J'ai des collègues coéquipiers
ququi se sont suicidés. Il faut
papasser un message très clair.
SoSouhaite j'entends ça depuis
hihier soir, la ligue nationale
dodoit faire si... on a l'impren
ququ'ils ne le feront pas, qu'il
vava avoir à peu près trois mate
memettons et qu'on va passer à n
auautre appel.
- - Vous savez pourquoi, parce e
lala ligue nationale est la pour
plplaire à ses partisans. On aie
lele jeu physique, on veut voire
lala violence et des bagarres. n
a a un commissaire qui est un
hohomme d'affaires, c'est pas un
spsportif. C'est pas un homme qi
s's'est battu ou qui a été frapé
dudurement, c'est un homme
d'd'affaire qui veut faire faire
dede l'argent aux propriétaires.
IlIl veut donner aux partisans e
ququ'ils veulent. Ce qui est
vevendeur, c'est du sang. C'est
plplate à dire comme ça, c'est
sésévère, mais ce qui est vende,
c'c'est du sang. J'ai de voir ce
quque la ligue nationale va
rérépondre. La culture, ça
cocommence je vous remercie d'en
paparler ce soir, parce que la
sesensibilisation et l'éducation
cocommence dans les maisons avec
leles parents, avec nos petits.
- - Ce que je ne comprends pas,
paparce que vous, vous étiez un
jojoueur dont la tâche était de
fafaire ça entre autres. Meilla,
vovous l'avez dit à plusieurs
rereprises, c'est une étoile de
l'l'équipe, c'est un marqueur, n
gagarçon qui en principe ne fait
papas ça. Qu'est-ce qui est arré
dadans sa tête d'après vous?
- - Je sais pas ce qui est arri.
JeJe vais appeler ça une crampeu
cecerveau. C'est justement poura
quque moi, je metsts en garde ls
jojoies, tous les joueurs qui st
susur les la glace de la ligue
nanationale de toujours se
prprotéger le parce qu'on sait
jajamais quand est-ce qu'une
écécervelée, une joueur étoile
cocomme lui peut avoir une crame
auau cerveau et servir un coup
d'd'une violence inouïe comme ee
l'l'a fait hier. C'est à nous
égégalement de bien prendre